manif contre l'islamophobie contre la
stigmatisation des musulmans qui aura
lieu le 10 novembre à paris notamment
avec la france a soumis ce n'est pas que
non mais c'est jean luc mélenchon qui va
y participer il l'a dit quel message il
veut envoyer et surtout acquis en
français c'est à dire quoi les français
sont islamophobes
vous ne voyez pas que dans le pays
montrent malgré tout un discours souvent
qui a tendance à considérer que les
musulmans ce responsable de beaucoup de
problèmes que c'est eux qui remettra en
cause la laïcité c'est le même que
contre les français et les françaises
c'est quand même étrange pardon c'est
une manière comme une ethnie j'ai pas
compris comme ça s'adresse aux français
ça s'adresse aux français de 10
rassemblons nous faisons preuve de
fraternité les musulmans ne sont pas les
mêmes d'un film d'amour faite pour vous
aujourd'hui qu'il voulait des noms il ya
là mêmes qui font profession à la
télévision et la vie qu on est dans les
locaux de l'ong à mourir non mais je
veux dire franchement je savais pas
quand je vois que monsieur zemmour que
j'ai eus connu une époque où il était un
des batteurs avec lequel on pouvait
changer mais qui arrivent en disant avec
un sourire que finalement le nazisme est
moins pire que l'islam et qui remet à ce
type de provocation extrêmement
blessantes pour beaucoup de gens moi
franchement je ne suis pas croyant et je
ne suis pas musulman
enfin mon vous pensez pas que ça blesse
des gens de dire c'est vrai le ménage
anti zemmour ce n'est pas une manif anti
zélande innovant vous me demandez
jusqu'où pas une manif en août et j'ai
du respect pour monsieur yves thréard
mais quand on y va on te l'a on va
débattre
sinon mes consignes et qu'ils n'en
parlerai tout journaliste puis ont
demandé des noms je veux remercier tout
elle a longtemps journaliste dit que
descendre d'un bus quand tu vois une
femme brûlée descente il d'un bus
continent avec une kippa maintenant
qu'il s'est excusé mais les dit il vous
me donnez un exemple
oui oui d'accord art apprend mieux si
les gens s'excuse après épique revenons
à ce qui s'est passé à bayonne il ya un
attentat d'un homme d'extrême droite qui
a voulu provoquer la situation sont
embrasés le pays en faisant le choix de
brûlé une mosquée et même de tirer sur
des gens c'est grave et bien de la même
façon que quand il ya des moments où il
ya des crimes antisémites dans le pays
je pense qu'il faut sortir dans la rue
pour dire non à l'antisémitisme qui a
aidé 2 il me semble culture
répondez à ceux qui jugent que vous avez
une démarche clientéliste voir
communautariste c'est ce que dit par
exemple le jardin de bardella le
rassemblement national
non mais c'est minable jeu
lui même ne serait même pas définir ce
que c'est ça c'est le côté quoi qu'ils
disent les choses en fait
il pense parce que je connais le coup
vous êtes clientéliste en fait vous fait
ça pour les arabes pour les musulmans je
connais c'est ça leur discours ils
n'osent pas le dire on invente des mots
aujourd'hui clientélisme de petites de
quoi parle-t-il
- je leur répète personnellement je ne
suis pas croyant mais je suis attaché à
la laïcité c'est à dire garantir la
liberté de conscience et la liberté du
culte il y a des français quelles que
soient nos opinions qui sont de
confession musulmane comme certaines
sont de confession juive comme certains
sont de confession catholique
voilà évidemment aussi attendez je veux
terminer mon propos est aujourd'hui il
est de bon ton de considéré que la
laïcité ne serait remis en cause que par
les musulmans
je vous ai amené un document voilà je
suis membre de la commission défense et
armés prochainement la dia le 11
novembre d'accord que tout le monde
connaît eh bien madame la ministre
darrieussecq chargé des anciens
combattants invitent à moi qui suis
député avec le bleu blanc rouge à
participer à une messe d'accord à une
messe est ce que moi je pense que la
laïcité il faut la défendre dans tout ce
qu'elle signifie c'est à dire je les
accusais 10 novembre c'est quand même
une manifestation qui est organisée par
le ccf qui est non l'équipe contre
l'islam organisé par l'union des
organisateurs est pas et pas des
moindres en tête de liste quand même il
faudra pas venir après dire que vous
êtes taxés d'islamophobie schiste mais
non mais vous voyez le vous utiliser un
vocabulaire je vais vous dire une chose
moi quand madame mireille cnom a été
assassiné j'ai parti une manif contre
l'antisémitisme
il y avait des fascistes de la ldj la
ligue de défense juive qui nous ont
agressés qui ont eu des propos
homophobes et qui ont été tolérés par
les organisateurs du crif
pour autant je ne regrette pas je ne
regrette pas d'être allé à cette
manifestation
ce que je vais vous démontrer c'est
qu'il arrive parfois qu'on manifeste que
dans une manif là des gens qui n'ont pas
mes positions
par ailleurs vous parlez du ccf je vais
aller à l'essentiel sont pas vos
positions j'ai entendu dire qu'il ya des
gens qui ont des propos beaucoup mais
moi je suis pas évidemment je ne défends
pas moi je suis envahi les frères
musulmans mais d'accord mais moi ce
n'est pas mon cas ça vous est jamais
arrivé faible part donc vous êtes
journaliste mais moi ça m'est arrivé
dans ma vie
ce qui m'intéresse c'est la peine
l'appel en question la paix dit des
choses qui sont un appel si je puis dire
à la fraternité et à la concorde et à
dire dans ce pays quand on est un peu de
mémoire de votre côté vous reconnaissez
bien que c'est une dérive de l'islam
les internes criminalisation oui les
attentats grecs qui sont vieux qui sont
commis mais en l'occurrence la
manifestation elle part de l'attentât de
bayonne on est d'accord que c'est grave
si une mosquée une synagogue avait été
attaquée tout le monde serait sorti dans
la rue
là c'est une mosquée on a le droit de
dire pour autant il faut faire envoyer
un signal de fraternité à à nos
concitoyens musulmans mais vous n'avez
pas répondu a fait que les mêmes qui
nous choque la laïcité et mettez en
avant
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
je le donne comme exemple n'en est en
baisse non mais attendez vous pardon de
cet effet rhétorique ce que je veux dire
c'est que si on défend la laïcité on la
défend elle n'est pas peut pas être à
géométrie variable
voilà c'est ce règlement notamment la
messe pour nous pour les catholiques
mais la ministre n'a pas invité le
député que je suis a participé à une
messe
elle mériterait à la mosquée el
m'inviterait à la synagogue voyait alors
ce que ces 5 me qui le climat que je
veux dénoncer c'est celui là si des
musulmans ne respectent pas la laïcité
doivent être condamnés mais la laïcité
s'applique à tous et les musulmans ne
peuvent pas être désigné dans les pays
comme étant les seuls les accords alors
voilà ce que j'ai dit car dans leur
grande majorité de ceux que je connais
rien ce sont des gens qui veulent
respecter la loi et qui veulent vivre
dans la paix la concorde et cannes ont
ras-le-bol pour les soul matin et soir
de sur leurs malheurs